on to Bravo the bag Chaser welcome home
thank you thank you man I had to come
[__] with my boy had to sit down for a
sec glad you're out it never happened
yeah man how you feeling man you good
you get out my whole thing is how you
pass time when you're locked up bro I
know it's different for everybody uh
just reading books I already gang bucks
shooting dice
um eating [__] eating a lot
what's the spread what's your spread
game like my spray game is crazy man
what
and like cheesy manwiches you know you
might you know you might uh sandwiches
out of soup and [__] cheesy manwiches
yeah absolutely you crush up a tip right
put some boiling water in there some
cheesy chips right
and then it become like a sauce and then
you thought you throw the soup in there
like a little Patty so you boil the
chips until it's a sauce no so you crush
up the chips throw some boiling water in
there then it's like a sauce okay I got
you got you and then you throw in um the
soup
like just the the square you know you
don't break it down bam throw it in
there let that [__] cook so the cheese
gets all up in there yeah take it out uh
put some cucumber some summer sauces
some chicken all up in there fat ass fat
ass Manwich oh
yeah is this something you'll eat now
that you're not incarcerated man hell no
I seen a pack of soup in my cabinet I
was like that's it that should look
disgusting I just know guys like who
will still make up [__] like they're
still in prison and I'm like guys you
guys know you think there's real food
now yeah I think that's just bad luck I
think if you eat that [__] out here that
you know yeah cause you're kind of
putting it out there yeah I'm straight I
love it man oh yeah yo
um yeah it was crazy because we were
just talking from North Hollywood which
is [__] where my Studios at yes sir
it's an area in the LA
uh greater metropolitan area that I feel
like a lot of people are familiar with
because a lot of artists record here yes
sir and it's also kind of like
one of the main places if you move to LA
to chase your dreams you get a spot in
NoHo yeah hell yeah everybody be
recording out here you know it's just
popping out here but it's also like it's
like baby Hollywood it is but it's also
like very a very active place like we're
in the valley so people think when they
come here they think like oh West
Hollywood North Hollywood Hollywood they
don't understand like they're totally
separate they're not close like if you
were to go from North Hollywood to
Hollywood if there's traffic it might
take you like 45 minutes you know what
I'm saying and if not it's like 10
minutes yeah so it's yeah it's quick
because you you know you just [__]
hop over but
um yeah what was it like growing up in
North Hollywood well I was growing up
all around the valley but like up until
my later years I was in North Hollywood
but what high school did you go to I
went to Opportunities For Learning okay
San Fernando shout out to San Fernando
best Mexican food Jesus and uh man La
got the best Mexican food off top off
the rip I think San Diego is a little
better yeah why because we're right next
to the board it's closer to me it's a
proximity thing I've never tried it I
you know but I never tried oh yeah
I've been downtown and hit the [__] in
the glass District
where do you go you go to the little
stands or something yeah and then you go
to like Chula Vista is it Chula Vista is
that what it's called
and then also you could just park at the
border
and then walk over and just get that
[__] just get that [__] huh yeah I don't
know that should be crazy out there I
don't know about walking but yeah but
like for you what was it like kind of
because the valley I feel like you know
there is such a um
if you're in L.A everybody knows about
the valley I feel like if you're not
from L.A you know a lot of people will
say the valley but it's it's separate
you know what I'm saying like it's his
own ecosystem its own politics its own
Vibe like what was it like kind of just
coming up in the valley man uh I mean
you know just same old [__] just
you know like uh try not to getting
[__] I was locked up like a lot of
my juvenile you know when I was a when I
was a teenager just [__] you know gang's
a game you know how that should go out
here yeah
it's just all the [__] you see on TV
that's what it is
you do the like La politics ever spill
over to the valley or is it like
separate it's all like at the end of the
day it's all the same politics like if
you know you know like you know right
it's the same politics from LA to the
valley to the [__] AV it's all the
same politics how many times have you
been locked up
uh highlight three four
what is a why is this last time going to
be your last time
because it's a rap like I said going for
myself back then I didn't have to say
going for myself yeah and I was just out
there [__] around like
you got a lot to lose man there you go I
got a son now too so that [__] hit there
how's your son he's two oh yeah you got
like a real little dude man I got a
little man yeah I just spent I just had
him he walking and [__] he walking and
[__] talking a little bit he's jibbering
and [__] yeah I had um I had him over
the weekend for two days and I haven't
had them like you know yeah so it was
just dope we Reviving it felt good he he
loved the love is there you know so [__]
I got a son I gotta make it home to my
son yeah you gotta make it home to your
kid and you got to make sure that you
have like a a real like you know
you can help build his future you know
what I'm saying like sorry you could be
there to kind of like guide him through
[__] you don't want to miss his his
developmental yeah I'm sure you probably
missed his ass while he was locked up
hell yeah well I'll see him sometimes
through a glass yeah yeah she was cool
they said counties like a really like
scary place it's the county you know and
then it it it it is you feel me like if
you go up in there and you don't know
what you're doing but
you know I was in there chilling the
whole time I was in there I was GP too I
was with everybody you're in general
population you're dead homies general
population the whole time it's crazy
because when I got there when I first
got uh busted when I was in the IRC
I'm walking and it's like a young
Mexican cop you know and then he's like
oh [__] like he's like Bravo like he's
like what's up man like whoa I'm always
good you know and then he starts playing
my [__]
on the like on the little speakers when
we're getting buck oh [__] on my son man
I'm done he's playing my [__] he's
playing my new [__] I'm like damn like
you know I look at him like that's
what's up you know I can't really talk
to him and [__] and then so um
so what happened was uh when we was like
in the tank when we was about to move oh
no we're going to the showers we all
butt ass naked you know they give you a
shower roll we walking he was like um
he's like hey you want to go to general
population want to walk the main line or
you want to come with us and I was like
I'm gping the whole way he's like all
right thing you know
these flies is crazy right this flies
like gonna [__] be the death what the
[__] is happening bro yeah yeah crazy so
you
first of all I would have been like I
would go with y'all
I'ma just go kick it with y'all where we
going little [__] yeah so for you like
is it because I can only imagine like
being somebody who's famous in La uh
being someone who's famous in hip-hop
period like
is it is it harder do you have a harder
experience in jail like do people like
have to like do you feel like people
[__] with you more man no no hell no it
was like people people was like oh they
see me and they didn't want to come up
to me and said I thought I was gonna be
like weird or stuck up or Hollywood and
[__] right and um
and then yeah I was getting hate too
don't get it [__] up you know it was
love and hate like I had people come up
to me like what the [__] yeah what you
doing here like you know I'm like it's
time [__] I'm sitting down you know and
I became cool with a lot of people I met
a lot of real [__] I haven't seen some
of my homies was fighting life and
they've been fighting that [__] for
years and I was like damn I was never
gonna run into you and I ran into you
here we eating together right family and
so um yeah it was weird but at the end
of the day like I had I was solid I had
my solid group of people everywhere I
went and uh yeah bro how did these flies
turn into two flies
dog
[__] bro I like I swear to God
this shit's like annoying just for for
everybody watching on camera there's
some fly [__] going on in here for real
besides his cookie sweat suit all right
hell yeah it's a big burn man give me a
roast it